I was in two in two different
institutions
um scary place I was actually 12 when I
got admitted there and then it was like
I spent my 13th and 14th birthday there
why were you there because your dad said
you shouldn't have been there you know I
came to the conclusion that everybody
has their own agenda you know my mom had
her own agenda I don't know exactly what
that was but my agenda was to make it
out on top of that tough spot at the
time Kate said Collins
institutionalization was due to quote
special needs you can't do anything
without
realizing he's missing Colin wasn't
there each unique child is receiving
exactly what they need your mom said
Colin has special needs there's a fairly
fluid diagnosis of what those needs are
this has been a struggle we've had for a
very long time and it's one I've dealt
with on my own I felt very alone in this
by the same token it's not something
that has only impacted me or him our
entire family has been impacted when you
hear that what do you think
um it's unfortunate that that's how my
mom you know
phrased me as a person you know I don't
see those things and I don't think
anybody else sees those things but
that's how she sees me then you know
that's her point of view and and I hope
that if we met again one day she would
understand that you know it's not the
case but you shouldn't have been there
is what you're saying to me no
um what did that do to your relationship
with her
um after being there I didn't have a
relationship with her even before that I
don't think we had much of a
relationship and um
I think that just kept tearing it even
more down Colin told me he was finally
able to leave the institution after
writing John this gut-wrenching letter
begging for help quote you're my dad My
Savior Please help me I'm counting on
you to get me out of here Daddy I love
you you wrote a note to your dad as a
matter of fact you might have even
written in crayons and you asked him for
help to get you out of that place right
um what was going on
um I was in a dark place mentally
um I think being in a place like that
does more damage than than it helps you
um so I was hopeless
um and and you know I figured out how to
write to my dad and I was kind of one
thing that that kind of helped me
mentally figure out that there was a way
out of there and you know a second
chance you know Redemption if you would
um so it gave me hope in my future for
sure Colin moved in with his dad and
twin sister Hannah in 2018 John says he
was granted temporary full custody your
mom didn't show up to the custody here
did it bother you she didn't show up it
didn't really bother me I mean they just
gave it to my dad and you know she
wasn't there to put her word in so
that's what happened
how has life been for you and Hannah
together
um oh Hannah I would do anything for my
sister and I love her to death Hannah uh
she was a big part of
um you know my emotional support she
helped me out a lot and still does to
this day you know she does so much for
me how is your relationship today with
your dad
um it's good I would say it's like every
other son and dad I mean we butt heads a
lot
um
it's just pretty normal sadly Colin's
relationship with Kate and his six other
siblings remains estranged but he is
hopeful that eventually it can be
rebuilt it's a mommy and a baby bear
oh well where's everybody else if
there's a message you could send to your
mom what would you say to her
um it's unfortunate that we didn't have
a relationship I think every son wants
to have a relationship with their mom
um but I'm doing very well
um and and yeah I think I'm good so
but you would love to have a
relationship with her if you could yes
that it would be ideal do you get to
talk to your other brothers and sisters
no I have not spoken with my siblings
and and probably five or six years now
um and it's tough you know I would love
to have a relationship with them I would
love you know for us to one day come
together you know have dinner together
talk you know just have the relationship
and catch up on the things that we that
we lost the time that we lost do you
want to send a message to them because
I'm sure they'll see this
um I love like I love my siblings I mean
you know I love them to death you know
they're the only
hmm sorry no I get it there's nothing
like the bomb between brothers and
sisters
there you wanna do you can somebody get
the tissue real quick okay grab a tissue
don't want to smudge the makeup
there is no shame in loving your
siblings not at all though can you
actually just re-ask questions yeah yeah
what would you like to say to your
siblings
um I love them very much and you know
kind of how I see it is without parents
involved it's just me and them and
um I really hope that you know one day
when I have kids that you know my kids
will know their Aunt uncles
what's the biggest misconception about
you
uh the biggest misconception about me
um is that I'm incapable or you know
that that you know I'm still kind of
hung up on the things that I've been put
through because I'm not
um you know I work just like everybody
else I go to school you know hang out
with my friends you know my life is
great but Collins busy schedule did lead
to a terrifying scare earlier this month
when he fell asleep at the wheel and
flipped his car look at this picture
that's scary that is scary
what happened
um I was on my way to work it's like two
in the afternoon and I'm working
full-time in high school so I'm tired um
fell asleep with the wheel next thing I
know
um car was flipped and I'm just like
sliding upside down across traffic and
and uh you know I just wanted to relay
the message to other people to wear
their seatbelt to not fall asleep with
the wheel but just drive carefully let's
talk about right now what's in your
future what are you doing now
um well I'm still in high school so
um finishing High School graduating
um I'm looking at the Marine Corps you
know I've always wanted to be a marine
so I think that's the next step
um but there's definitely I have a lot
of Dreams a lot of goals I mean
countless do you have a girlfriend uh no
I don't don't just rocking it out you
know would you ever do reality TV again
um
you know I think you know I've become
somewhat of a natural at it so I think
it'd be cool to kind of do it now that
I'll I'll probably remember the memories
of it and and I'll see it a little
differently too versus not remembering
it when I was younger thank you so much
what do you remember about doing the
show
um well I don't remember like the depth
of it or like the little details
um something that you never forget it's
like the presence of the cameras like
there's always cameras there they're
always on you Colin is stubborn yet kind
fans watch Colin since he was three
years old growing up on TV John and Kate
Plus Eight was one of TLC's highest
rated programs ever can you stop
breathing so loud honey
he's like
it was such a phenomenon that in 2009
10.6 million viewers tuned in to watch
John and Kate's televise separation
announcement uh Kane and I have decided
to separate I'm not very fond of the
idea personally do you wish your parents
could have stayed together to work
things out
you know it would be nice
nobody wants their family to be torn
apart but I I do wish they could have
made something work out they don't speak
now do you wish they could at least they
would speak to each other if they had
the capability of co-parenting that
would be nice you know they don't need
to be best friends but it would have
been nice if they could be adults about
it and get along and do it for the sake
of their kids if you guys hadn't done
that reality show do you think your
family would be intact
um I think so yes you know I think the
pressure of being in front of the whole
world and you know everything you every
mistake you make is is out there
um I think that was a big influence of
them not being together and I definitely
think they'd still be together so John
and Kate Plus Eight basically ruined
your family
I think so in my opinion
[Music]